el parque de su hogar de retiro fue el
único horizonte que su sano observó
durante los meses de confinamiento esta
residente de 91 años estuvo encerrada en
su habitación sin poder recibir visitas
me sentí como una condenada era una
cárcel ni siquiera podría salir al
corredor me traían mis comidas en la
mañana en la tarde y en la noche sin
interacción nada era horrible me dije no
es posible si hubiera habido una ventana
abierta habría saltado al vacío no podía
más sostén olvida
susan todavía siente el trauma de esos
meses de aislamiento extremo sanando eso
me marcó profundamente todavía lo siento
no logré exteriorizar lo en este momento
tenemos la moral un poco abajo
desde otoño susan va a un psicólogo el
sufrimiento moral puede tener
consecuencias tangibles sobre la salud
de las personas mayores los riesgos son
muy conocidos en los servicios de
geriatría el extremo es lo que llamamos
el famoso síndrome de deslizamiento hay
los pacientes realmente tienen una
pérdida de motivación importante se
dejan ir dejan de comer dejan de
hidratarse no vuelven a caminar es
realmente una emergencia médica por eso
es muy importante mantener ese vínculo
social para evitar ese síndrome
depresivo
ante la amplitud del malestar y del
aislamiento de los mayores para el
segundo confinamiento el gobierno
decidió mantener las visitas en las
residencias
de lavar el pelo esta mañana y de
peinarme
cristian sur a tu viene con frecuencia a
visitar a su madre momentos de
complicidad lo que marcan el ritmo de
vida de marcel de 94 años no lo es pero
yo sé que va a venir entonces lo espero
que estés aquí es lo principal
las reglas son estrictas no más de dos
visitas a la semana máximo durante una
hora antes venía a verla mínimo tres
veces a la semana
las primeras veces había dos mesas y
ella estaba ahí al otro lado de la mesa
y nos hablábamos así ya no podemos
abrazarnos eso es difícil y fue un
desastre cuando prohibieron las visitas
mi madre me decía es mejor morirse de
kobe o de tristeza en junio en múnich o
vino de tristes este problema del
aislamiento no sólo afecta a quienes
están en las residencias sino también a
muchos adultos mayores que viven solos
en sus casas de hecho la asociación de
los pequeños hermanos de los pobres
publicó un informe alertando sobre el
tema
durante el primer confinamiento de más
de 700.000 personas mayores de 60 años
no tuvieron contacto con su familia
y 650.000 personas no tuvieron ningún
confidente el confinamiento fue duro
para todos nosotros en tour imagínense
cómo debió ser para quienes no tuvieron
a nadie con quien hablar en un cajón
para reconstruir un vínculo social la
asociación lanzó junto con dos aliados
el programa parís en compañía
esta iniciativa incita a la movilidad de
las personas mayores y lucha contra su
aislamiento rose marie de 89 años se
inscribió hace unos meses
así fue como encontró a eloise de 22
años nos llevamos bien de inmediato me
pareció muy amable es verdad que nos
llevamos bien desde la primera vez que
nos encontramos entonces decidimos
volver a vernos
las dos mujeres pasean por la orilla del
canal una vez a la semana una bocanada
de aire fresco para rose marie que es
viuda no tiene hijos y hace poco perdió
a su hermana de forma a veces lloramos
pero el momento pasa
a esa gran soledad se sumó el ambiente
taciturno de los múltiples
confinamientos
con solo que hubiera ruido poder ver a
las personas pasar cualquier cosa pero
ahí estaba todo muerto por completo no
se escuchaba nada no estaba
completamente aislado incluso aunque uno
no salga tiene la impresión de estar
bloqueado no me quedó demasiado pero a
veces es duro la fe de después se
decidió el aislamiento de las personas
mayores no sólo se limita a las grandes
ciudades en sar queman en el gran este
chantal una voluntaria de los pequeños
hermanos de los pobres visita a los
adultos mayores
viudo y sin hijos
antoine participaba en las actividades
de la asociación hasta el confinamiento
a veces hacíamos viajes durante el año
hacíamos meriendas
es triste ya ni siquiera podemos darnos
la mano nada
le hace falta el contacto físico
sí claro cuando no siempre estás solo
eso es pero ahora todo parece dividido
ya no es lo mismo
la crisis sanitaria agravó la soledad de
las personas mayores
que ya vivían aisladas en francia 300
mil adultos mayores están en una
situación considerada como muerte social
casi no tienen contacto con su círculo
social